1 sur youtube il existe de nombreux
formats qui cartonne les podcasteurs
comme le faisait alors début norman
cyprien où mr vie salut à tous et mr
ripley gamer comme squeeze bienvenue
dans cette vidéo ou encore les stars du
tuto comme enjoy phoenix l eau tout le
monde j'espère que vous allez bien mais
ces dernières années les stars de la
plateforme sont devenus les enfants
déballage de jouer expérience chansons
souvent poussés par leurs parents
nombreuses pour les 6 12 ans à poster
régulièrement du contenu sur leur chaîne
youtube et pour certains ces petites
activités du dimanche s'est transformé
en véritable business
on peut citer par exemple athena et cali
star du studio bubble tea et en 1.5
million d'abonnés ou encore ne-yo et
swan qui sont de véritables célébrités
2.0 avec leur 4.5 millions de fans les
vidéos de ces derniers très stimulés par
la mère présente dans presque chaque
vidéo ont soulevé de nombreuses
critiques beaucoup leur reprochant de se
faire exploiter par leur maman dans une
vidéo publiée en 2010 est néo s'était
exprimé sur le sujet les gens sur
youtube n'importe quoi sur nous sur moi
sur ma mère n'importe quoi
ne soyez pas des moutons ne les voyez
pas pour beaucoup cette vidéo elle même
était à l'initiative de sa maman et
comme les enfants sont mineurs les
dizaines de milliers d'euros générés par
ces chaînes vont directement sur le
compte des parents aujourd'hui si les
deux garçons continue à poster
régulièrement du contenu la polémique
n'en est pas moins présente
alors selon vous les enfants sur youtube
se font-ils exploités par leurs parents
[Musique]
je vous donner quelques salaires en
numéro 3 pas de celles qui gagnent le
mieux sur youtube c'est anastasia rajin
sky à 18 millions de dollars à leurs
sacs ont également en 2019 à la gagner
18 millions de dollars à vous entendez
bien à cinq ans
jude perfect 20 millions de dollars et
le numéro un c'est ryan kajyn il a huit
ans et il a gagné 25 millions de dollars
en 2010 à l'opus ouais c'est incroyable
à 8 ans voilà il a gagné il a gagné 26
millions de dollars c'est complètement
ouf c'est vraiment est ce que ça vous
choque ou pas moi ça me semble que ce
soit content ça me choque je sais pas ce
que je voudrais c'est qu'on puisse
légiférer qu'on puisse encadrer et en
même temps c'est impossible
en fait c'est un voeu pieux parce que
comment encadrer un travail qui est à la
maison on peut encadrer des enfants dans
le monde du spectacle parce qu'ils ont
des heures par exemple au cinéma peuvent
pas tourner plus demandeur contexte il
faut qu'elle fut et voilà mais là
puisque ça se passe à la maison avec les
parents je vois pas comment un
inspecteur pourrait venir en disant ding
dong
combien de temps il a il a été devant la
télé comme un temps était dans sa
chambre donc c'est impossible
jean-michel serait choquant si les onces
ans pelé ni si l'on n'était pas content
alors les parents les engueuler
verta-ray arrêtent de travailler la
jouer à la playstation
la vie rêvée pour un gamin n'était pas
vétuste et vidéos tels les gamins qui
font des vidéos avec une nonchalance et
une sorte de saturation
ils sont comme des suds eu des cadeaux
qu'ils ouvrent franchement ça ressemble
plus à du travail dissimulé qu'autre
chose
j'ai la justice a été saisie pour
travail illégal d'enfants
il ya la convention la convention des
droits de l'enfant c'est le droit de
l'enfant est protégée contre
l'exploitation économique donc on est en
plein dedans il ya un flou juridique que
les parents utilisent alors ils mettent
ça sur un compte bloqué évidemment que
les enfants vous l'avez dit or on a 18
ans mais néanmoins il ya de plus en plus
d'associations qui disent que c'est
dangereux et que les parents exploite
les enfants moi ça me choque
oui faut ni moi par exemple à partir du
moment où l'enfant il n'est pas forcé à
être sont les réseaux sociaux moi je
pense que c'est bénéfique pour les
parents et pour les enfants à partir du
monde ça devienne l'exploitation pour
l'enfant alors là ça devrait plus tard
oui tester les jouets ou alors oui
tester des jeux ou alors ils ouvrent
délire samedi 8 mai l enfant parce que
vous trouvez pas qu'il ya une certaine
jalousie aussi à moi c'est ce que je dis
bah oui kelly non parce que je pense
quand même que
que faudrait pas les forcer faudrait
juste pas les forcer parce qu'à un
moment donné les parents voient que ça
qui gagnent de l'argent et même pour eux
c'est une spirale ils veulent toujours
gagner plus c'est normal c'est l'humain
qui veut ça et à partir du moment où ils
vont gagner plus belles vouloir que
leurs enfants fassent plus et c'est
peut-être ça le problème il est là elle
est là la limite skis à sainte maxime
rouquet isabelle tu te plains pas contre
tes parents et c'est vrai qu'au début
c'est un jour effectivement il n'ya rien
de plus drôle que de jouer à la
playstation europe et au bout d'un
moment tu as une saturation c'est
d'accord avec maxime avec kelly on a vu
des vidéos où tu vois que les gamins ils
commencent à saturer
alors c'est pas de la génération a cédé
au travail après son fils de bourgeois
atari son fils au début c'est pour rire
mais après ça devient un vrai travail ça
veut devenir maman s'était pas lâcher
donc je comprends qu'ils aient des
enfants un moment donné ça laisse où
c'était très marrant mais après c'est
les parents qui sont en train de forcer
les enfants allaient à l'étude je trouve
qu'on n'est pas en train de faire un
faux problème
ouais moi j'ai l'impression qu'à chaque
fois qu'un truc qui marche mais le
flinguer le truc je vous dis faire des
enfants et surtout mais serait plutôt de
foutus au turbin bons conseils toi toi
avec la vie avec lui et on est pas mal
de gens m'ont fait citer comme moi
savent eux aussi variés que dire des
téléspectateurs tiens oui ak oui
ça ça dégueulasse des gens mais on est
d'accord avec les téléspectateurs